I'm so lucky Chandler's such a blessing
and always kind and wonderful Bindi
Irwin lucky and in love with hubby
Chandler Powell the couple's been going
strong since 2015 after this meet cute
moment two years earlier when I first
met Chandler I had the first test was
the Echidna food I think so I just gave
him some Echidna food and made him feed
the Echidna and it was pretty good so
anyways I was I'll give you some of this
and then I'll tell you what it is a
bonding moment you know you you become
part of the family when you feed an
Echidna yeah and and you can tell it's
just really fun yep thanks to an Echidna
also known as a spiny anteater the pair
sparked a friendship which turned
romantic two years down the line that's
when Bindi made things Instagram
official with this birthday shout out
we're a wild family you know to tell you
the truth Chandler of Florida native
made the big move to Australia in 2018
after studying Wildlife like the irwins
channel is actually really amazing when
it comes to Wildlife I think that's
because he's such a kind and caring Soul
fast forward to bindi's 21st birthday in
2019 the lovebirds got engaged Tim is
the light of my life he is my other half
and I am so grateful that we met now
when it came to saying their ideas Bindi
and Chandler had plans for a big bash
the most important thing is is getting
married here at Australia Zoo because
this is where I feel closest to Dad
that's what we need the most and with my
family it'll be really special it will
be but things took a turn during the
covid-19 pandemic and the two pivoted to
an intimate ceremony with just three
guests bindi's mom Terry her brother
Robert and her late Dad Steve Irwin's
best friend Wes Manion it's something
that when you lose someone that you love
so much throughout the rest of your life
you're going to wish that they were
there for those milestones
Steve died when Bindi was just eight
years old in 2006 but earlier this year
her family told ET how they're honoring
the original Crocodile Hunter's Legacy
with their show crikey it's the irwins
sharing your life with everyone and and
keeping keeping the beat going on I
think he would be so excited he'd be the
most excited of all it's important for
us all to remember that we are all
leading a legacy and I think it's so
terrific that Bindi and Robert are
carrying on and now the legacy is
expanding to another generation Mindy
and Chandler welcomed their first child
together last year the baby girl Grace
Warrior Erwin Powell we are the proudest
parents we love her more than life
itself and and watching Chandler grow to
become such an incredible dad it's
really really special he loves Grace so
much she just she's Inseparable with
Chandler they do everything together and
I can't wait for her to be running
around with him and ah my word it's it
is nothing quite like it so your channel
and I we we didn't want to name Grace
until we had met her and held her and so
when she was born
um as I was holding her for the very
first time I said she's our graceful
Warrior and those were the first words
that I spoke to her and Chandler and I
looked at each other and we just went on
my word that's her name that's it and it
just fell into place perfectly and their
bundle of joy well Bindy says she's
fitting right into the family business
it's so special for for us getting ready
for the next generation of wildlife
Warrior Grace is just always with me no
matter what whether we're at the
Australia Zoo Wildlife hospital or in
the middle of a management meeting she
is always with me and watching her soak
in the world around her has been truly
magical she's got that determination
that Steve had and that connection with
Wildlife because it is we weird to see
animals just gravitate to her and all
the kangaroos just gather around her
like they're having a meeting oh my God
the koalas I don't need to interrupt but
the koalas literally climb out of their
trees
cheers to the couple and their growing
family she is just the light of Our
Lives
[Music]